VIOLATION, THE SECOND TIME IN
THE PLAYOFFS HE GOT THAT.
MISSES THE FREE THROW.
HARRIS THE REBOUND.
>> Mark: GIVE THE BUCKS CREDIT.
GIANNIS HAS BEEN ADJUSTMENTS.
THEY MADE ADJUSTMENTS.
DOMINATED THE BALL AND PUT THEM
IN A BETTER POSITION.
>> Mike: NEARLY KNOCKED AWAY BY
HOLIDAY.
THIS IS A VERY PHYSICAL GAME.
IRVING THROWS IT IN.
GOES DOWN HARD ON HIS RIGHT
SHOULDER.
HE'S SHAKEN UP.
NOW HE'S HOLDING HIS RIGHT LEG.
FIVE ON FOUR.
IRVING STILL DOWN.
CONNAUGHTON CAN'T HIT THE THREE.
REBOUND GRIFFIN.
NOW THEY'LL BRING IT UP.
THE TIME-OUT IS CALLED.
KYRIE IRVING HOLDING THAT RIGHT
SHIN.
BANGING THE COURT.
NETS, OF COURSE, HAVE HAD THEIR
SHARE OF INJURIES A